here with us
because she's such a
great voice
for the faces of those that we have lost
the human beings that we have lost
as a result of fentanyl poisonings
and that's what it is ladies and
gentlemen they're not overdoses it's
poisonings
and we've had 70 something thousand
individuals die from fentanyl-related
deaths in the last year to put that in
perspective when we were freaking out in
the 80s over cocaine we're talking about
10 000 a year
this is 70 something thousand over 107
000 deaths
related to drugs in the last year
you can die from one to two milligrams
of fentanyl and that fits on the end of
the point of a pencil
but the people were talking about dying
one pill can kill they take xanax they
take some pill they take something they
think is fine it's got a fentanyl in it
boom they're dead we had a high profile
texas football player from the
university of texas died a year ago
taking xanax leads to fentanyl
four kids in hayes county where i live
hayes county texas in the last month
from fentanyl poisonings
it's happening everywhere in this
country it's happening every day 150 to
200 people a day
and that fentanyl is pouring into our
country through poorest borders because
our border patrol are processing people
because of this administration's
policies rather than actually patrolling
the border the cartels know it they're
leveraging it to run fentanyl into our
communities and people are dying and one
last point on that at a human level and
then i'm going to turn it over to my
friend michael cloud he's one of the
strongest advocates for border security
and defense of texas alongside these
great law enforcement officers and
people like virginia
this is a human problem
this is a problem about people
right i'll hear a lot you'll hear
virginia will hear others parents who
have lost their loved ones to fentanyl
this isn't a
red problem or blue problem right
they said yesterday in a round table we
had over the hill that we have to do as
republicans by the way on a partisan
basis because my democratic colleagues
refuse to do it
and we pull people in the room and we
hear stories from yesterday 12
moms and dads mostly moms
who walked us through their losses
this is a human problem
this is a problem of losing our loved
ones
whether it's
virginia's beautiful daughter tiffany
or whether it's
the migrants that we've seen dying in
the rio grande or in south texas
we've seen it in real time i was down at
the border and i think michael might
have been with me we were down at the
border when they found the body
of our national guardsmen in the river
going across to try to save somebody
coming across the river that same day
not in the news were the three migrant
bodies found in the rio grande just down
the river from where that national
guardsman was found
this is a human problem it is solvable
and it is time that this administration
acknowledge the problem and engage in
taking out the policies that we need to
put in place to stop it
one final message to my republican
colleagues it is not enough to give lip
service
to border security it is not enough we
are going to demand out of our
republican leadership that we secure the
border of the united states and that we
not fund one more penny to a department
of homeland security that refuses to
secure the border of the united states
with that i will yield back yield to my
friend mr cloud
thanks chip for your leadership on this
thanks fair for hosting this virginia
for being here to share your story so
important and of course to the law
enforcement on the front lines of what
we see happening in our communities
every single day and what's happening in
this country is tragic it's horrific
that this administration continues to
aid and embed cartels and destabilizing
central and south america and wreaking
havoc in the communities in our country
and we're seeing the the hypocrisy of
the left unravel in ways we haven't seen
before you know it's uh 50 people get
killed in texas and they don't care but
50 people show up in obama's backyard
and suddenly it's a big deal and uh you
know we've gone from cities saying
they're sanctuary cities to of course
just a just a fraction of what happens
in texas every single day happens in
their communities and uh their message
turns around completely and you know
it's our communities have been dealing
with this for a long time my district is
just two hours north of the southern
border and we live in what law
enforcement has dubbed the fatal funnel
where there's a couple major highways
that come from the border
into houston it serves we know as the
human trafficking capital of the united
states of america which is something
that we should be fighting we should not
be allowing organizations who traffic
humans who spread drugs into our
communities to to continue to have their
free will and free reign and the truth
is is they have the the operational
control of the southern side of our
border uh and and as much as borders are
will come up and tell you that oh we we
have control of the border anybody who
knows anything knows that's an absolute
lie and it's time that this
administration stop lying to the
american people about what's happening
across the border because as chip just
said
tens of thousands of people are dying
china's sending chemicals into the
cartels paying them to ship it into the
united states this is a major national
security issue it's a major human issue
and for us to continue you know if your
political policy
uh it has to cooperate with evil
organizations like the cartel it's
probably the wrong political approach
and so this administration needs to
reverse course dramatically needs to
secure that border and we do need big
bold leadership in congress and when the
house flips in november we're going to
expect that we're going to demand that
we're going to demand that we stop
funding bad administration and bad
policies because we've we've got to
support the good work that these men and
women are doing to safely secure our
borders this has to stop we've got to
stop these cartels from wreaking havoc
on our country thanks so much for the
great work you're doing thanks for
hosting this and keeping this message
alive and we'll keep the work and try to
get you guys some support
uh next i'm going to turn it over to
virginia krieger who has become a great
activist on you know illicit uh
narcotics coming into this country she
tragically lost her daughter
to a fentanyl poisoning several years
ago and she's leading a rally with a her
large organization around the white
house tomorrow so again we encourage
everybody to attend that as well
thank you everybody for coming today
my name is virginia krieger i'm the
co-president of lost voices of fentanyl
and i'm the founder of parents against
illicit narcotics
organization which i founded after the
death of my only daughter tiffany to a
counterfeit pill
that was made up of fentanyl and pill
binding powders it wasn't laced
it was a completely faked pill made to
look identical to a trademark
pharmaceutical product we call percocet
tiffany wasn't your typical victim
like many
she didn't have
need recovery services she didn't have
substance use disorder she hurt her back
somebody offered her a pill because she
was in pain that happens every single
day in this country
somebody has a headache a friend offers
them a pill an act of love an act of
compassion
and now that act of compassion can kill
we were comfortable and we've been
blessed
up until now that we've never had a
counterfeit pill problem let alone a
deadly counterfeit pill problem but we
have one today
up to now we've been stuck in the old 15
year old opioid crisis
the old kind of crisis where people
would use drugs they would fall into
drug addiction and they would need help
and they would have 30 to 40 years of
chances to get better
and live their lives
today the greatest risk to our children
is this new group being affected
every friday night when they go out with
their friends and they might try ecstasy
they might try a line of cocaine people
who never get addicted
in the past are dying now
this is a whole new demographic and we
haven't addressed it at all
fentanyl continues to pour into this
country
through the mexican cartels through our
southern border this administration
knows it and they've done nothing about
it where are the psas where's the
covet-like response
we are eight years into a crisis we are
burying
72 000 last year alone
to fentanyl that is more than the
20-year vietnam war
and nothing has been done
everybody in this country should know
fentanyl is there it should be a
household word within 30 days of covet
everybody knew wear a mass social
distance wash your hands we're eight
years in and our kids still don't know
about these fake pills
so this weekend bereave families are
coming from all over this nation
bereave families
this is the face of this new crisis this
is the face
our banners will be on display
we have 21 banners with 56 faces each
of our children
and they're gone
they can never come back we're not here
for ourselves we should be having a
memorial event but we can't do that
we have to march to the white house to
beg them to please do something please
warn these families please stop the
fentanyl from getting in this country
you know what you know who and you know
how
do something we're asking them to please
talk to our families to find out how
that fentanyl got to our children
instead of assuming
we need recovery and addiction services
absolutely but we also need to address
the poisoning piece of this crisis and
please when you talk about fennel don't
say that word overdose
because when you say that you're
implying that my daughter our children
went out and they sought fentanyl they
wanted fentanyl they got fentanyl and
they simply took too much and that is
not what is happening
anytime a person hides or disguises a
harmful substance and anything for
another to consume without their
knowledge or if they disguise it as
something else to deceive
that's a poisoning that is not an
overdose
we need to start addressing the real
root issue here and let me add
these poor migrants that come here they
are more victimized by the cartels than
we are
these people are fleeing for their lives
from these brutal cartels who have taken
over every country to our south and
they're in control not us not the
mexican government
we're asking our this administration to
look at the lives that we're losing to
look at the victimization of the people
to our south
and to start taking care of human beings
because that's what we need
this is not a red or blue issue
this fentanyl crisis can affect anyone
fentanyl is an equal opportunity killer
it does not care if you are dnc or gop
and we need to stop acting like it is
this isn't political this is about our
children
where's our military going to be in 20
years
what's what are we going to do with
these children growing up without their
parents who are traumatized already we
buried a seven-year-old last week
a 10 year old we're finding fentanyl
pills in middle schools
the president said the greatest risk to
this country was from
far-right conservatives
i disagree
the greatest risk to our country is
comes every friday night
when your child leaves the house and
they might get influenced to try a drug
the old message used to be
just say no don't do drugs you might get
addicted and ruin your life
today the message has changed
the message is don't try that pill don't
do that drug because you could die
we have to get on board with this new
crisis we need all our health agencies
to talk to these families we need to
start interdicting this fentanyl before
it even gets here we need to address
china
and their mass production of it
we need help and the biggest thing we
need is for every country every family
in this country to know
this can happen to you i said not me
not my child until the day it was
thank you so much for coming i hope that
you'll join us this saturday at our
rally
it begins at 9 00 a.m we will have 50
victim banners on display
and we are marching to the white house
we'll be there from 12
to 2 15 p.m
and then we'll continue our event back
at the national mall
at the 12th street gravel area until 6
pm come talk to these families
get their stories
and please help us we need it
thank you
thank you so much virginia i'm going to
turn it over to three sheriffs right now
we're going to start with uh sheriff
brett schroetlin sheriff schroedlin was
elected sheriff of grand county colorado
in 2015 and he's also currently
president of the western
state sheriff's association and he's
been in law enforcement since 1992. i'll
turn it over
good morning everyone as you said brett
shortland i'm the sheriff in grand
county colorado and also the president
of western state sheriff's association
which encompasses the 17 western states
many people ask what is the colorado
sheriff doing here in d.c or what is the
colorado sheriff actively involved in
our border crisis and fentanyl crisis
because we see and are impacted by it
every day it's a critical critical
critical component of our law
enforcement profession
3 000 sheriffs across the country are
experiencing the fentanyl crisis are
experiencing the border crisis
it is not just our border sheriffs it is
not just the southern border that is our
issue the southern border is the gateway
into the law enforcement issues that
we're experiencing today
the increase in violent crime the
increase in drugs increase in fentanyl
methamphetamine
deaths
deaths is a key word law enforcement is
experiencing deaths all across this
country every day due to the lack of
action the lack of action by our
administration which is critical
as we move forward we have to think
about
cooperation communication and
coordination those three key words are
critical in our profession as we move
forward
as we collaborate we work together as we
cooperate we have to make sure our
message goes out there collectively
together and we have to do that through
communication one of those steps of
communication is standing here today
standing here with fellow sheriffs with
community leaders with fair with
families to make a difference we need to
get our message out there unfortunately
there's way too much negativity in
today's world that the negativity
message is coming out we have to get out
there with the facts and the facts are
is that our southern border is unsecure
the fact is that our cartels are running
our nation
and people are dying as we were just
experiencing people are dying as a
result of these decisions and so as we
stand here today together
we stand unified we stand unified as
sheriffs we stand unified as communities
we stand here unified to make a
difference because it's now time to act
it's time for us to continue acting as
sheriffs it's time for our congressional
leaders to act as congressional leaders
and it's time as our president and
administration to act
together as well so as sheriffs
especially sheriffs from the west
we stand united and we stand with our
handout to our administration to solve
this problem we can't do it individually
we can do it collectively and so we ask
for that collective approach as we move
forward thank you
thank you next up is uh sheriff thad
cleveland from tarot county texas who's
also a former border patrol agent
good morning and uh sherry thank you for
for having me up today and and uh for
all your hospitality and shuttling us
around we appreciate that also like to
thank our congressman for for joining us
from from texas
i come from the 23rd congressional
district the largest congressional
district in texas and and i know my
congressman is in town and uh
unfortunately he's not here it'd be nice
to be supported by him as well but i'm
here to talk about something a little a
little bigger than that
talk about border security i spent 26
years united states border patrol the
last 11 years were in my hometown of
sanderson texas i was the patrol agent
in charge of sanderson
unfortunately our sheriff passed away he
was a 30-year veteran of the of the
united states border patrol santiago
gonzalez and i took an appointment to
replace him and will be elected in
november to that position
we talk about border security it is
national security we talk about the
crisis along the border it's real it
doesn't matter if you call yourself a
republican a democrat if you call
yourself red or blue
at the national level the problem goes
unfixed it's a solvable problem i can
tell you that it's nothing we haven't
experienced before
we can fix it it's just we choose not to
and i like to compliment governor abbott
on what he's done because what he's
doing is he's taken out of our backyard
in texas and getting them out of our
communities and then they send them to
other places send them to your front
yards
they'd end up there regardlessly but
he's getting them out of there quicker
so we don't have to to pay for that
burden
we talk about the area i come from
terrell county we have 91 mile well the
county itself has 54 miles of water with
mexico
the the border patrol station there is
in charge of 91 miles of border which is
the third largest amount of border with
the u.s mexico border and it's part of
the big bend border patrol sector which
is the westernmost portion
of
texas and it contains 500 miles of water
so that's a quarter of u.s mexico border
and we don't see the flows like you see
in del rio which is at the eastern end
of the 23rd congressional district or el
paso which is now surpassed
del rio with illegal alien activity
apprehensions
but in my county we continue to grow
we've had about a 600 increase and it's
a drop in the bucket compared to what
goes on other places
this year we're going to surpass
7 000 apprehensions again that sounds
like a small number but in my area where
i'm sure
they're not looking to surrender they're
not looking for some sort of political
asylum or political relief what they're
looking for is to abscond in the united
states and continue their trek northward
undetected i can't say enough about what
our border patrol agents do out in that
area the amount of work they do
um the amount of hours they put in
it's just tremendous
we still talk about fentanyl and i'm
honored to be able to speak tomorrow
ma'am thank you for for inviting me
our cartels
are controlling our border
100
they're shaping the border they're
crossing illegal aliens where they want
to cross them
that way they can occupy border patrol
agents who that's our authorities to
arrest those who come into the country
legally we have to process them and it's
leaving huge gaps in the border and
again i want to reiterate it it's it's
not a fault of our border patrol because
they're doing earth they can do they're
just not supported and of course we talk
about the recent hiring of 87 000
folks with irs you know we've got 19 000
border patrol agents you know we need
more agents we need more technology we
need more infrastructure along our
border
i look forward to continuing our talk
tomorrow
i speak to you truthfully about the
border if you have any questions i'm
free i'm available but at this time i'd
like to introduce
the judge at terrell county if i could
step online just a little bit and let
her speak to uh
to some of the other problems we face in
terrell county judge carruthers
hello i'm terrell county judge dale lynn
carruthers i it's an honor for me to be
here today thank you for inviting me
as you as the gentlemen that stand
before me and ladies of law enforcement
i'm honored to be
with him today
congressman thank you thank you for
having us here
um and i'd like to take one moment
to
sincerely tell you our condolences from
terrell county ma'am
i'm not only the terrell county judge
but i am also a rancher
i
live our ranch is 17 000 miles and it
butts up against mexico
and i'm here to tell you that this is an
invasion
they are coming across the border and
the ones that come through terrell
county typically are not family units
they are people in camouflage they are
they are coming across the most rugged
desert terrain imaginable
and
they are
trafficking drugs
there are high speed chases
and we're having to deal with it on a
daily basis
texas is not a gateway
they're trying to use it as a gateway
once it hits all these other respective
states that are standing before and
behind me
it's it's all over the united states
america this is a problem it is our
problem and we need to get a hold of it
we need to get a grip
it's not just something that we're going
to shove under the rug and pretend like
it doesn't exist
it does exist there is a border crisis
and i am a female in law enforcement
that is sitting here telling you
it exists i took my oath just like
everyone else when they take their oath
and they represent an office in this
great united states i'm not here to tell
you a lie
there's a crisis
and we're standing here together today
to let you know
that we truly
care about the sovereignty of the united
states of america and
we're here to defend it thank you so
much
thank you so much judge and then we're
going to conclude with one more sheriff
sheriff scott jenkins from culpepper
county virginia he's the only remaining
uh sheriff in virginia who's cooperating
with ice via the 287g program as well
good morning thank you for having me
as said i'm sheriff scott jenkins from
culpepper virginia
culpepper sits about an hour drive
southwest to where you stand today not
far
my message isn't a political rhetoric or
directed to one party or the other
it's not a red or blue issue democrat or
republican it's an american issue
i'm speaking as an american
a citizen but also
a cop for over 32 years
and a sheriff
for over a decade
this message is to every american and
every law enforcement officer in america
especially
to our president and all the members of
congress and every level of government
in this nation
government's first duty is the safety of
the citizens
to that end america must realize that
every county is a border county now
we must educate our communities that
it's time to protect america now
i've been sheriff during the terms of
president obama trump and biden
i've toured the southern border multiple
times
under both trump and biden i've seen the
results of their policy from d.c
the crime and violence that was once
across our southern border
has been given an open door
to now come to every town in america
i'm going to tell you about mexican drug
cartel activity
the crime and violence that's happening
in my county and that is only one hour
drive from where we stand today
an hour drive from the white house mr
president
the leading cause of death as we know in
young adults is fentanyl manufactured
mainly in china crossing over 90 percent
of it crossing the southern border
this week alone my detectives and
culpepper
have purchased enough fentanyl to kill
every man woman and child in my county
just this week
we purchased kilos of meth fentanyl
from the drug cartel themselves the
cartel is selling guns
laundering money in our county
we have houses of human trafficking in
our town
we have the sex trafficking
we have families working and living in
our community
paying off tens of thousands
owed to coyotes in the cartel
we even have property in our county that
they use for their gun training for
firearms for the cartel members
in december last year we had a shooting
at a christmas party in my county out in
rural culpepper county we had a shooting
all of the vehicles present at that
party had california and pennsylvania
license plates
we quickly noticed that 38 super was the
caliber of casings we found everywhere
on scene
those of you know firearms know that as
a choice weapon of the cartel
of course no one knew much of anything
but when we got with our partners at dea
and hsi we quickly learned we had hit a
cartel jackpot
months later the shooter from that
incident was located and arrested in
california surprise surprise in less
than a week before we could extradite
that person
he was mistakenly released from the jail
in california and hasn't been seen since
i could go on but what america needs to
know
is that what was once happening in the
backyards of american border towns in
the southwest
is now in the front yards of americans
all over our nation
my message to washington as a citizen is
to do your job or get out
fulfill your first responsibility
safety
secure our border first
identify everyone
who enters the country then you can
argue over the politics of who receives
centers of citizenship
that's a party issue
to everyone in that capitol building
if you do not
want our border secured
and to identify and record everyone who
crosses across our borders
then you are serving a political agenda
and not your oath of office
to the citizens of my county in culpeper
the people dropped off by those buses
coming from texas to d.c
they're not staying in d.c they're
coming to our county and counties all
over this region
i imagine you know that
and that's not a shot at the texas
governor
arizona or anyone else that's looking to
relieve their citizens of the burden
that they're facing i have seen it
firsthand
i have to respect what you're doing
you're trying to protect your community
but do we know anything about these
people no
we do not because the federal government
doesn't know anything
virginia has been receiving over 3 500
files on individuals crossing the border
every week for months 3 500 files on the
ones they know crossing the border come
to our ice office for virginia every
week where are these people living
they're in our towns
this does not include the thousands that
are coming that we don't know of
i'd like to give an
invitation to our president and his
administration and any member of
congress
who would like a briefing on the
information about the cartel activity in
virginia that i've just mentioned
you can take a short drive to meet me or
i'll come to you
this this is truly a crisis for our
nation and is the number one safety and
security risk to america at this time
i thank you for listening
i asked
one last thing
that america please continue to pray
and hope for the safety of our border
patrol ice agents and all of our law
enforcement are facing this enormous
battle without the support of our
federal government
thank you
[Applause]
thank you so much sheriff we're
concluding now does anybody have a
question of sorts yes yeah um i was
wondering if the sheriff's or anyone
here thinks that perhaps the governor
should just start sending them back over
the southern border rather than to other
parts of america where they're just
going to go into
other areas and just make the problem
worse for
everyone anybody want to take that
well i don't want to speak on behalf of
the governor of texas for sure but i
tell you the the immigration authority
lies with the federal government it
doesn't lie with state government
it like you know are we at the mercy of
them for
whatever duration
we should have been suffering for the
past couple years and i just want to
make a point that i'd make earlier about
policy so
each administration brings good and bad
policy um i've been a border patrol
agent since clinton through bush through
obama through trump and part of biden
and again there there's good policy and
then there's bad policy but we need we
need to change our laws our laws are old
and antiquated
and that's what we need we need to
change the laws so yes we'll continue to
suffer by policy change until we change
our laws and those laws are enforced
i'll add one layer to that and
in agreement we do need to change the
law
in significant part to
restrict the ability of an
administration like the current one to
adopt policies that are frankly in
direct conflict with existing law
we need to tighten down the laws so they
can't use loopholes to exploit
those loopholes in order to ignore the
actual purpose of the law to secure the
border to your question
i believe that there is an invasion i
believe that that does trigger
under the constitution the ability for
texas and other states to respond to
that invasion
i believe that we'd be well within our
rights and have the power to
turn people away at the border in order
to defend our state and that if this
current administration refuses to do its
job which clearly is their current
choice then it would be incumbent upon
states to turn away at the border now to
be clear that brings with that certain
complexities
this federal government
they would no doubt go after our law
enforcement if they were the ones doing
the turning away
we have 19 law enforcement officers in
austin texas getting sued because they
dared to stand up and stop the riots in
the summer of 2020.
what do you think will happen to law
enforcement if they're doing their job
when the governor says we've got an
invasion and we need to repel and turn
away
all of these leftists will go after our
good men and women in law enforcement so
if we make the step to do that then you
got to giddy up and make the step to do
that and all that comes with that but
we're getting to a point where states
are going to have to do their job to
protect their citizens right now i stand
side by side with governor abbott and
all that he's doing to do what the
federal government refuses to do you ask
any border patrol agent you ask any law
enforcement they'll say well thank god
at least the texas leadership is doing
their part to try to help and try to
fill the breach and that we should try
to stand alongside
any additional questions yes
i mean look i mean
forgive me if my response isn't bring it
um you know and and as i've said before
like welcome to the party right uh you
you want to complain as i said about
this dc city councilwoman about what's
happening here in dc we have 4 000 a day
crossing at texas and you're talking
about a couple of hundred when you have
a stash house 73 here in washington dc
or you want to complain about 50 going
to martha's vineyard when 53 human
beings died in a bus in san antonio
texas
which i represent 53 human beings
died burned up in a bus
and you want the administration wants to
sue
a governor of a state
for wanting to
send a signal to the country and that's
what this is about it's waking the
country up who are being lied to by an
administration by a secretary of
homeland security who looked me in the
eyes and lied
lied under oath
in the
house judiciary committee when he said
that this administration has operational
control of the border with a statute
sitting around in front of him he is a
liar
our secretary of homeland security lied
this administration lies the press
secretary every day lies
and they are causing people to die as a
result so if they want to come sue
the governor of texas or see the
governor of florida or any other
governor
bring it but just understand that they
have the duty to secure the border and
that they're the ones that are causing
human beings to die
any additional questions yes
sheriffs are
more than happy to follow the laws
and use any mechanisms given us
legally to deal with the problem
local law enforcement obviously doesn't
have the authority that federal agencies
do border patrol and ice
287 g is an example in virginia prince
william county once the last election
occurred
their local board being much more
left-leaning and liberal in their views
decided to
in that program that had been in place
for many many years i
currently am the only remaining program
in the state and we all know that ice
border patrol has become more or less
babysitters
escorts chauffeurs for the border and
most of our agents all across the
country are serving more time southwest
than they are at home doing their duties
in the states they're assigned
i
admire the ice agents that work here in
virginia that i know and work with my
staff
understands the position the predicament
that they're in and very little they can
do with this juncture and it's been that
way for well over a year and a half
elections have consequences as someone
once said and we are living through it
every day but america has to wake up and
realize it is not a partisan issue
government's first responsibility is
safety and they are not living up to
their oath
right any additional ones all right
um
my question is
the new york state health department
has said that there's a
safe uses for fentanyl
what would be your response to the new
york state health department
i would ask them to come and tell that
to the 19 point thousand bereave family
members in our facebook discussion group
any advocating of any kind for illicit
fentanyl use
should be is criminal
two milligrams can kill someone two
milligrams and less if they have
absolutely no no resistance whatsoever
to opiates
we had this is in the hands of children
children middle schools
did they think that this wasn't going to
bleed out
that it wasn't going to get to the kids
eventually
you know there was an article that came
out yesterday that
we have moms crying about from the
washington post that was minimizing the
risk to kids
they were talking about the rainbow
fentanyl and how that could get to
children and they were actually making a
mockery of this
this isn't funny
72 108 keep that number in your head
that's how many people we buried last
year and we're already past that for
this year
these are not these kids are at risk
every day
and nobody's doing anything and the fact
that they keep minimizing it the fact
they keep comparing street fentanyl to
pharmaceutical grade fentanyl is
criminal
acetyl fentanyl is not the same as the
kind of fentanyl they give you in a
prescription it's not delivered the same
it doesn't have the same potency
its molecular structure is different
and they need to recognize this and stop
our kids are dying what does it take to
get it through to people
you know we've been screaming and
begging begging on our knees for psas to
warn the public we've been begging
people to talk to us how did your kid
die and nobody stopped to even ask that
question
they just assumed oh they must have had
substance use disorder it's not true
anymore
so you know
these things happen and and it really
does it frustrates our families you know
we believe and and all the things that
we're trying to do to help those who
have substance use disorder
but this is a different drug we've never
dealt with before it's deadlier than any
drug we have ever dealt with before it
kills easier than any drug we've ever
dealt with before and process this if
you will
at any given time there's some unstable
person in this country driving around
with enough illicit fentanyl in their
hands to chemically take out an entire
city
why isn't that causing any alarm
why are bereaved families being forced
to spend their own money that's what
this weekend's about
you know we're spending our money to put
out psas we're putting out billboards
we're warning people we're going into
schools
and we've met resistance every step of
the way by people who say oh the war on
drugs failed this isn't a war on drugs
this is a war on fentanyl
there's a war against poisonings and we
can stop it and that's the most
frustrating part
i look at the moms today and if they
listen to us three years ago four years
ago a lot of them wouldn't be grieving
and my question to the congressman
yesterday in our meeting was what's
going to happen in 20 years when all the
parents the parents who bury their
children get old who's going to take
care of us
that's the next ripple effect that's
going to happen
who's going to take care of this
geriatric population of the 108 000 that
died this year you know family care is
the greatest thing that we have in terms
of our elderly who's going to take care
of me
my daughter's dead she can't take care
of me who's going to do it
the federal government
a nursing home
where abuse is rife people are
mistreated and abused and neglected is
that my future now
this is something we can do something
about we're not asking
to keep anyone out we're not talking
about people who are coming here because
they need a new life we're talking about
having basic security measures basic
common sense somebody to walk through
the same x-ray technology to get in this
country that i use to get on a domestic
flight
we can detect these drugs we can
interdict these drugs before they even
get here and now now with this if we
don't stop it if it diversifies into
india we will never stop it
and all i can say is people should
invest in a lot of body bags
because
i i fear what's coming down the pike
we've worn them and worn them and worn
them and it's doubling and tripling and
it's the numbers keep rising and
nobody's doing anything
we have to get serious we got to stop
arguing with each other and fighting
we're a family and our family's dying
let's work together and get it done
that's all we want
all right that's going to wrap things up
today thank you so much uh for coming
out and i encourage you uh guys to
mingle with the sheriff's or or the
members and and and virginia as well and
again virginia's event is tomorrow feel
free to reach out to anybody here at
fair if you want more details on how you
can cover it
it's going to be a very big event that
will resonate can i just clarify one
thing
i neglected to say her name but i want
to make sure i do our founder of lost
voices of fentanyl is april babcock
april babcock put it together a rally
last year at the chinese embassy and
most of you didn't even know we were
there but we were there last year
and uh so i just want to give her full
credit for creating this group for
building the rally
and i'm proud to be her co-president and
stand with her in this fight and uh
april also lost her son austin at the
age of 25
to
fentanyl poisoning
thank you
all right thank you very much